This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We often think of the media we consume as food for the mind. The right books, the uplifting films, the inspiring podcasts, we believe that these will make us wiser, kinder, better people. The Chinese philosopher Lao Tzu is supposed to have said, watch your thoughts, they become your words. Watch your words. they become your actions.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们常常把我们接触的媒体视为精神食粮。那些优秀的书籍、振奋人心的电影、鼓舞人心的播客，我们相信这些会让我们变得更明智、更善良、更好。中国哲学家老子据说曾说过：注意你的想法，它们会变成你的言语。注意你的言语，它们会变成你的行动。
Watch your actions, they become your habits. Watch your habits. They become your character. Watch your character. It becomes your destiny. By this logic, if we want to be good, kind, and ethical people, we should watch movies about good people, read books about kindness, and consume stories about high-minded individuals who always do the right thing.
注意你的行动，它们会变成你的习惯。注意你的习惯，它们会变成你的性格。注意你的性格，它会变成你的命运。按这个逻辑，如果我们想成为善良、仁慈和有道德的人，我们就应该看关于好人的电影，读关于善良的书籍，并吸收那些总是做正确事情的高尚之人的故事。
glance at any list of bestsellers or movies that crush at the box office, and you don't see many high-minded plots and altruistic characters. Now, you find people who lie and cheat, family members who betray one another, friends who are not good friends. If we are what we consume, surely this does not bode well for us. Nowhere is this tension more acute than in stories of violence, gore and killing, especially in horror movies. The goal of all the spattered blood, severed limbs, and blood-curdling shrieks is to make
看一眼任何畅销书榜单或票房大卖的电影，你都不会看到太多高尚的情节和利他主义的角色。相反，你会发现那些撒谎和作弊的人、背叛彼此的家庭成员、甚至算不上好朋友的朋友。如果我们吃什么就像什么（人如其食），那这肯定对我们没有什么好兆头。这种张力在暴力、血腥和杀戮的故事中尤为明显，尤其是恐怖电影。所有飞溅的鲜血、断肢和令人毛骨悚然的尖叫声，其目的都是为了让你
you horrified, not edified. If most of us want to be good people, what explains the enduring popularity of books and movies that show us not just the worst of human nature, but the worst that the human imagination can conjure? This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion episode for Hidden Brain Plus, why we crane our necks to observe car crashes, endlessly gape at videos of natural disasters, and deliberately subject ourselves to tales of murder and mayhem.
感到惊恐，而不是受到教化。如果大多数人都想成为好人，那么如何解释那些不仅向我们展示人性中最丑恶的一面、而且展示人类想象力所能构想出的最糟糕一面的书籍和电影，为什么能拥有持久的受欢迎度？本周在《隐藏的大脑》以及《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的特别伴随节目中，我们将探讨：为什么我们要伸长脖子去围观车祸，无休止地盯着自然灾害的视频，并故意让自己沉浸在谋杀和混乱的故事中。
What are the kinds of shows of murder and mayhem? and books we choose say about us. How do they shape us? Colton Scrivener is a researcher at Arizona State University and Orhus University in Denmark. He's a psychologist who studies why we consume certain stories and the effects those tales can have on our minds. Colton Scribner, welcome to Hidden Brain.
我们选择的谋杀、混乱的节目以及书籍，究竟说明了什么？它们是如何塑造我们的？科尔顿·斯里夫纳是亚利桑那州立大学和丹麦奥胡斯大学的研究员。他是一名心理学家，研究我们为什么会消费某些故事以及这些故事对我们心智的影响。科尔顿·斯里夫纳，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Hello, Shanker. Thanks for having me on. Colton, as a kid, I understand that your favorite movies were those featuring Indiana Jones, such as Raiders of the Lost Ark and the Temple of Doom. What scenes in particular were you drawn to in these movies? Yeah, I loved those movies as a kid. I still love them as an adult. I've probably lost count of how many times I've seen them.
你好，尚卡尔。谢谢邀请我来。科尔顿，据我所了解，你小时候最喜欢的电影是印第安纳·琼斯系列，比如《夺宝奇兵》和《魔宫传奇》。在这些电影中，你特别被哪些场景吸引？是的，我小时候非常喜欢这些电影。直到成年后我依然很喜欢它们。我可能已经数不清看过多少遍了。
I do remember watching them, you know, on repeat as a kid. And, you know, I could never remember the names of them. You know, there's Raiders of the Lost Ark. There's the Temple of Doom. there's the Last Crusade but I always remembered them kind of by specific scenes and so I would remember
我确实记得小时候一遍又一遍地看它们。而且，你知道，我总是记不住它们的名字。你知道的，有《夺宝奇兵》。有《魔宫传奇》。还有《圣战奇兵》。但我总是通过具体的场景来记住它们，所以我会记得
you know oh well this one was the one where there were a lot of rats or this one was the one where there was a big snake or this is the one where the guy's face melts like an ice cream cone and those scenes were always the ones I guess that's why I remembered them by that I remembered them by kind of the violent scenes
你知道的，哦，这一部是有很多老鼠的，或者那一部是有大蛇的，又或者这一部里有个家伙的脸像冰淇淋筒一样融化了。这些场景总是那些最吸引我的，我想这就是为什么我通过这些来记住它们的原因——我是通过电影中的暴力场景
or scary scenes that were in the films So Temple of Doom, if someone asked, have you seen Temple of Dune, and I'm a kid, I would say, well, I think so, which one was that? Is that the one where he pulls his heart out of his chest and it's still beating? That's kind of how I would, you know, that's how they sat in my mind. So one theory might be that we seek us. out dramatic stories about violence and gore because our own lives are boring and humdrum. But there's research that suggests that in the aftermath of scary things happening in real life,
或者恐怖场景来记住它们的。所以如果是《魔宫传奇》，如果有人问，你看过《魔宫传奇》吗？而我当时还是个孩子，我会说，嗯，我想看过，那是哪一部？是那个他把别人的心脏从胸膛里掏出来而且心脏还在跳的那部吗？这就是我当时对它们的印象，这就是它们在我脑海里的存在方式。因此，一种理论可能是，我们寻找关于暴力和血腥的戏剧性故事，是因为我们自己的生活无聊而单调。但有研究表明，在现实生活中发生可怕的事情之后，
there's often a surge of interest in scary entertainment. In the early 1970s, a young woman, a college student, was murdered on the campus of the University of Wisconsin. A team of psychologists studied the subsequent entertainment choices of students on that campus. What did they find, Colton? what the psychologists were studying was what kinds of films the participants would choose as a reward for taking part in a study, like a psychological study. And in this case, in the town they were in, there were two films that were in theaters. There was Truman Capote's in Cold Blood, and then there was kind of a rom-com, and I can't recall the name of that one. But what they found is that after this murder occurred, the students on the campus were much more likely to choose the scary films.
人们往往会对恐怖娱乐产生激增的兴趣。在20世纪70年代初，一名年轻女性，一名女大学生，在威斯康星大学校园内被谋杀。一组心理学家研究了该校学生随后的娱乐选择。科尔顿，他们发现了什么？心理学家研究的是，作为参与一项研究（比如心理学研究）的报酬，参与者会选择什么类型的电影。在这个例子中，在他们所在的镇上有两部正在上映的电影。一部是杜鲁门·卡波特的《冷血》，另一部是一部浪漫喜剧，我记不起那部叫什么名字了。但他们发现的是，在这起谋杀案发生后，校园里的学生更有可能选择恐怖电影
as a reward for taking part in a study. I understand that the researchers even drill down and found that students who were in the same dorm as the victim were more likely to watch the scary movie than students who were in different dorms. Correct, yeah, if you think about this like a heat map, you know, where you have different colors and the closer you got to this dorm, you know, the rhetoric got,
作为参与研究的奖励。据我所了解，研究人员甚至进行了更深入的挖掘，发现与受害者在同一栋宿舍楼的学生，比住在不同宿舍楼的学生更有可能观看恐怖电影。没错，是的，如果你把这想象成一张热力图，你知道的，你有不同的颜色，你离这个宿舍越近，你知道的，颜色就越红，
the more likely they were to choose to go see Truman Capote's film. So a couple of decades later, in the early 1990s, a super violent video game called Mortal Kombat was released. Two different versions of the game were made available to the public. Why were two versions made available, and how do they fare, Colton? Well, Mortal Kombat kind of broke ground in video games. It came about at a time when, You know, video game consoles were moving from purely being an arcades to now being in the home.
他们选择去看杜鲁门·卡波特电影的可能性就越大。所以在几十年后，即20世纪90年代初，一款名为《真人快打》的超级暴力电子游戏发布了。该游戏向公众推出了两个不同的版本。科尔顿，为什么会推出两个版本？它们的表现如何？嗯，《真人快打》在电子游戏领域算是一个突破。它的出现正值这样一个时期：你知道，电子游戏机正从纯粹的街机厅走向家庭。
You know, you were having these new stories coming into households. And what you had is you had a couple of sort of big players, I guess, who were able to sell Mortal Kombat. And one of those was Nintendo Entertainment Systems, which, of course, is still around, still very popular. And they had the Super Nintendo Entertainment System, and they wanted to release Mortal Kombat. And then you had the Sega Genesis platform. And the difference between these two is that Nintendo kind of had cultivated this family-friendly approach to video games. And so when this super violent game came out, you know, where you could engage in these finishing moves, where you pull an opponent's spine out of their back and hold it up like a trophy, you know.
你知道的，这些新故事开始进入千家万户。当时的情况是，有几个算是行业巨头的人能够销售《真人快打》。其中之一就是任天堂娱乐系统（Nintendo Entertainment Systems），当然它现在依然存在，而且非常受欢迎。他们推出了超级任天堂娱乐系统，并且他们想要发布《真人快打》。然后你还有世嘉MD（Sega Genesis）平台。这两者之间的区别在于，任天堂在电子游戏方面一直培养的是这种家庭友好的路线。所以当这个超级暴力的游戏问世时，你知道的，在游戏中你可以使用那些终结技，把对手的脊椎从背部抽出来像奖杯一样举起来，你知道的。
And of course, this is all just sort of pixelated, you know, early 1990s graphics, but still quite violent. What Nintendo decided was that that was simply too much for their family-friendly approach to video games, but they knew that Mortal Kombat would be successful. So the compromise they struck was that for their systems, the blood in the game would actually be turned to kind of a grayish color. And they called it sweat rather than blood. It's almost like the fighters were sweating instead of bleeding. And many of the finishing moves had to be altered or removed entirely from the game.
当然，这一切都只是像素化的，你知道的，20世纪90年代早期的图形，但仍然相当暴力。任天堂决定，对于他们家庭友好的电子游戏路线来说，这实在有些过头了。但他们知道《真人快打》会大获成功。因此他们达成的妥协是，对于他们的系统，游戏中的血实际上会被改成灰白色。而且他们管这叫汗水而不是血。这几乎就像格斗手们在流汗而不是流血。并且许多终结技不得不被修改或直接从游戏中移除。
Now, Sega, which was a much smaller video game company at the time, and, you know, Super Nintendo Entertainment Systems outnumbered Sega by probably five to one in American households. And Sega kind of took a big bet on Mortal Kombat and said, no, we're going to show it in all of its, all of its gory glory. And so they And so they left it as blood, they left all the finishing moves as they were and surprising to Nintendo I think the Sega Genesis version of the game outsold the Nintendo version of the game by several factors
现在，世嘉在当时是一家小得多的电子游戏公司，而且，你知道的，超级任天堂娱乐系统在美国家庭中的数量可能比世嘉多出五比一。世嘉在《真人快打》上可以说是孤注一掷，并表示：不，我们要原汁原味地展现它所有的血腥荣耀。因此他们世嘉
Wow. So in other words, even though it was much more violent, and even though many people might say, you know, we are not a fan of violence or we are appalled by violence, the video game that was the more violent version, the very same video game, and its more violent version outsold the Tamo version. Correct. And that's, you know, as a scientist, like, wow, that's the perfect study you could set up, right? And the video game industry kind of accidentally set that study up for us. Let's skip forward in time to 2020 when the COVID pandemic hit. People who were stuck at home without much to do but stream movies chose one movie in particular to watch, even though it was nine years old at that point. Here's a clip from the movie in which a research scientist is talking to a public health administrator. I thought you said that once we could grow it, we could vaccinate against it. We tried using dead virus combined with several agents.
就这样保留了血腥，保留了所有的终结技原貌。出乎任天堂意料的是，我认为世嘉MD版的销量在多个倍数上超越了任天堂版。哇。换句话说，尽管它暴力得多，而且尽管许多人可能会说，你知道的，我们不是暴力迷，或者我们对暴力感到震惊，但那个暴力得多的版本——同一个电子游戏，其暴力程度更高的版本销量却超过了另一个版本。没错。而且，作为一个科学家，这感觉就像，哇，这就是你能设置的完美研究，对吧？电子游戏行业某种程度上意外地为我们建立起了那项研究。让我们快进到2020年新冠疫情爆发之时。被困在家中无所事事、只能看流媒体电影的人们，偏偏选择了一部特定的电影来观看，尽管当时它已经上映九年了。以下是该电影的一个片段，其中一名研究科学家正在与公共卫生官员交谈。我以为你说过，一旦我们能够培养它，就能针对它进行疫苗接种。我们尝试使用死病毒结合几种剂型。
to boost immune response. And? No protective antibodies, a lot of dead monkeys. Can you get to the part where there's good news? Now we have to try a live attenuated virus. Like with polio? Exactly. The only danger with a live virus is the possibility
来增强免疫反应。然后呢？没有保护性抗体，死了很多猴子。你能讲到有好消息的那部分吗？现在我们必须尝试减毒活病毒。就像针对小儿麻痹症那样？正是如此。使用活病毒唯一的危险在于
that it will revert to wild type and kill the host. So this was the 2011 movie Contagion. What was it about, Colton? So Contagion was essentially a film about a global pandemic, and what we thought a global pandemic would look like, not just in the form of the virus itself and how it would spread, but also how people would respond to this? What would be the social response to this global pandemic? So I understand that Google Trends data kept track of the popularity of this movie, and in 2019,
它有可能恢复为野生型并杀死宿主。所以这就是2011年的电影《传染病》。科尔顿，它是关于什么的？所以《传染病》本质上是一部关于全球大流行的电影，以及我们认为全球大流行会是什么样子的电影，不仅是病毒本身的形式及其传播方式，还有人们将如何对此做出反应？社会对这场全球大流行的反应会是什么？所以据我所知，谷歌趋势（Google Trends）数据追踪了这部电影的热度，而在2019年——
this is the year before the pandemic, the movie was averaging around six on a scale of one to 100 in the popularity index. By January 2020, as the first reports of the pandemic, was sweeping across the world, the popularity surged to 84, and by March 2020, when mass closures hit the United States and other countries, it hit 100, the very peak of search interest. Correct. So those Google Trends data do a great job of showing you what are people interested in in relation to a particular topic or movie. So with Contagion, the most popular that it had been was in March of 2020, despite having come out nine years earlier. And despite at the time, I believe it was only available on one streaming platform.
也就是疫情爆发的前一年，这部电影在热度指数1到100的量表中平均分大约为6分。到2020年1月，随着疫情的第一批报告席卷全球，其热度飙升至84；到2020年2020年3月，当美国和其他国家实施大规模封锁时，它达到了100，即搜索热度的最高峰。没错。因此，谷歌趋势数据在展示人们对特定主题或电影的兴趣方面做得非常出色。所以对于《传染病》而言，它最受欢迎的时候是在2020年3月，尽管它是在九年前上映的。而且尽管在当时，据我所知它只在一个流媒体平台上架。
Now, in one level, this is very puzzling, right? People are terrified about the pandemic. There's a lot of uncertainty. There's a lot of worry. And what do they choose to do in their spare time? They go and watch a movie about another pandemic? That seems to be what they did. Yeah, at least many people did.
从某种程度上来说，这非常令人费解，对吧？人们对疫情感到恐惧。有太多的不确定性。有太多的担忧。而他们在闲暇时选择做什么呢？他们去看了一部关于另一场大流行的电影？这似乎正是他们所做的。是的，至少很多人都这么做了。
You know, it shot up from on the Warner Brothers catalog. I think it was ranked like 270 or 271 or something like that. And it had shot up to being the second most popular movie on the catalog overnight. During the pandemic, Colton, you say that another type of movie also surged in popularity. What was this type of movie? Well, this may come as a surprise to some, but horror movies kind of had their time to shine in 2020 and 2021. And so what you saw was that kind of in the early year or so of this pandemic, this new novel threat that the world was facing,
你知道的，它在华纳兄弟的片库里的排名从——我想它当时排名在270或271左右。而在一夜之间飙升至该片库中第二受欢迎的电影。科尔顿，在疫情期间，你说另一种类型的电影热度也飙升了。这是什么类型的电影？嗯，这可能会让一些人感到惊讶，但恐怖电影在2020年和2021年确实迎来了它们的高光时刻。所以你看到的是，在这场大流行初期的大约一年里，在世界面临这种新的未知威胁时，
people were seeking out scary movies more in relation to other kinds of movies than they ever had before. So on the surface cult and this is puzzling, many of us say we want to be good, kind, and thoughtful people, and yet many of us seem to be drawn to stories of gore and violence. One of the things that I've noticed in my years as a podcaster is the sheer size and enduring power of the true crime podcast industry. Millions of people just can't seem to get enough of stories of kidnappings and murders and violent crime.
人们对恐怖电影的追捧程度相比以往任何其他类型的电影都要高。所以表面上看，科尔顿，这很令人费解，我们中的许多人说我们想成为善良、仁慈和有思想的人，然而我们中的许多人似乎又被血腥和暴力的故事所吸引。在我作为播客主持人的这些年里，我注意到的一件事就是真实犯罪播客行业的庞大体量和持久影响力。数百万人似乎永远也看不够绑架、谋杀和暴力犯罪的故事。
Yeah, I mean, ever since podcasting has kind of taken off, true crime has always been in the top five or top 10 of most popular podcasts. genres. Parents, pastors, and pundits denounce violence and other forms of antisocial conduct. But as consumers of entertainment, we seem to eagerly soak them up. When we come back, why we find ourselves rubbernecking on the highway as we pass a car crash and what our fascination with tales of murder and mayhem reveal about our minds.
是的，我的意思是，自从播客兴起以来，真实犯罪一直是最受欢迎播客类型的前五名或前十名。父母、牧师和权威人士谴责暴力和其他形式的反社会行为。但作为娱乐消费者，我们似乎却急切地将其大肆吸收。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么我们会在高速公路经过车祸时忍不住伸长脖子去看，以及我们对谋杀和混乱故事的迷恋揭示了我们的心智怎样的秘密。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In countries around the world, people tell each other's stories about the worst of human nature. Children whisper tales to each other about ghosts. and goblins. Adults eagerly read news accounts of crime and violence. The gorier, the better. And in the aftermath of disasters, researchers find many people are more strongly drawn to fictional tales of violence and vengeance. Colton Scrivener is a researcher at Arizona State University and Orhus University in Denmark. Colton, in his 1871 book, The Descent of Man,
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在世界各地的国家里，人们互相讲述关于人性中最丑恶一面的故事。孩子们互相低声诉说着关于鬼魂和地精的故事。成年人则急切地阅读有关犯罪和暴力的灾难新闻。越血腥越好。而在灾难发生之后，研究人员发现许多人更强烈地被虚构的暴力和复仇故事所吸引。科尔顿·斯里夫纳是亚利桑那州立大学和丹麦奥胡斯大学的研究员。科尔顿，在他的1871年著作《人类的由来》中，
Charles Darwin tells a story about a group of monkeys at the zoo what was the story he read about So Darwin had heard this story that a group of monkeys would seem to be fascinated by the thing that they should fear the most which for a group of monkeys is a bag with a snake
查尔斯·达尔文讲述了一个关于动物园里一群猴子的故事，他读到的是什么故事？达尔文曾听说过这样一个故事：一群猴子似乎对它们最应该害怕的东西着迷，对于一群猴子来说，那是一个装着蛇的袋子。
and Darwin was so fascinated by this that he actually ran an experiment himself trying to replicate this What did he do? He took a bag and he put a snake in it, and he went to the London zoological gardens, and he put it, I don't know if he specifies what kinds of monkeys they were, presumably rhesus macaques or something like that. He put this bag in their exhibit, and he noticed that the monkeys would slowly walk up to it, like one monkey, the bravest monkey, would slowly walk up to the bag, peek inside, and shriek. They would yell, and they would run away. And you would think, like, okay, that should signal to the other monkeys that they shouldn't look inside this bag because there's something bad in there.
达尔文对此非常着迷，以至于他自己实际上做了一个实验，试图复制这个实验。他是怎么做的？他拿了一个袋子，把一条蛇放了进去，然后他去了伦敦动物园，把它放进了——我不知道他有没有指明那是哪种猴子，大概是恒河猴之类的吧。他把这个袋子放进它们的展区，他注意到猴子会慢慢地走过去，比如有一只猴子，最勇敢的那只猴子，会慢慢走到袋子旁，往里面偷看，然后发出尖叫。它们会大叫，然后跑开。你会觉得，好吧，这应该向其他猴子发出信号，告诉它们不应该往这个袋子里看，因为里面有不好的东西。
Hmm. And it did signal that there was something bad in there. But what Darwin found was that the other monkeys then decided they needed to take a peek. So they would one by one slowly creep up to the bag, peek inside, see the snake, shriek, and run away. And, you know, this absolutely fascinated Darwin. And he saw this as a form of almost human-like curiosity. He writes, monkey after monkey, with head raised high and turned on one side, could not resist taking a momentary peep into the upright bag
嗯。这确实发出了里面有坏东西的信号。但达尔文发现的是，其他猴子随后决定它们也需要看上一眼。于是它们一个接一个地慢慢蹑手蹑脚地走到袋子旁，往里面窥视，看到蛇，尖叫着跑开。而且，你知道的，这绝对让达尔文着迷。他认为这是一种近乎人类般的好奇心。他写道：一只接一只的猴子，昂着头，歪向一侧，无法抗拒地想要对这个直立的袋子进行短暂的窥视，
and the dreadful object lying quietly at the bottom. So the monkeys represent an example of what is sometimes known as predator inspection. What is this, Colton? Predator inspection is really interesting because, you know, In the same token as with the monkeys and the snake, you might expect that if a zebra sees a lion on the savannah or a gazelle sees a cheetah, that they should just run away, right? I mean, why would the zebra do anything else other than run away
以及静静躺在底下的可怕物体。所以猴子代表了一种有时被称为捕食者监视（predator inspection）的现象。科尔顿，这是什么？捕食者监视真的很有趣，因为，你知道的，正如猴子和蛇的例子一样，你可能会预料到，如果斑马在萨凡纳草原上看到狮子，或者瞪羚看到猎豹，它们应该直接逃跑，对吧？我的意思是，为什么斑马在捕食者进入视线范围内时，除了逃跑还会做别的事呢？
when their natural predator is with an eye shot? But oftentimes what they will actually do is stand very still and look at the predator. And what's really interesting about this is that you know, there's some differences in which animals are looking at the predator and when they choose to do so. You know, the gazelles will choose to look at the cheetah more often when they're in a larger group, when they're a bit further away from the cheetah. And it's not evenly spread among the groups.
但通常情况下，它们实际做的是静静地站着，看着捕食者。而这其中真正有趣的地方在于，你知道的，哪些动物在观察捕食者以及它们何时选择这样做，这其中存在一些差异。你知道的，瞪羚在处于更大的群体中、距离猎豹稍微远一点时，会更频繁地选择观察猎豹。而且这种行为在群体中的分布并不是均匀的。
So the gazelles that are adolescents or sub-adults are much more likely to engage in predator inspection. And what is the logic, the evolutionary logic, logic to these actions. Yes, of course you have to ask why would a prey animal stop and take a look at its natural predator instead of running away. And the logic here is that in many cases in nature, prey animals live in very close proximity with their predators. And so every time you see a lion, if you're a zebra and you run away, you're going to be running for most of your life, right? And that's actually worse for you. You're going to be expending calories that you would otherwise be saving. you are going to be spending time running instead of grazing.
因此，处于青春期或亚成体的瞪羚更有可能参与捕食者监视。这些行为背后的逻辑、进化逻辑是什么？是的，你当然得问：为什么猎物动物会停下来观察它们的天然捕食者，而不是逃跑呢？这里的逻辑是，在自然界的许多情况下，猎物动物与它们的捕食者生活在非常近的距离内。因此，如果你是一只斑马，每次看到狮子你都逃跑，那你大半生都得在逃跑中度过，对吧？而这实际上对你更不利。你会消耗掉你本来可以节省下来的卡路里。
It's actually going to put you at higher risk of being caught later on. So that's one sort of side of the coin of the logic. The other side is that if you don't know much about your natural predators, you're kind of in a bad spot, right? It's good for you to be curious about them because if you can learn a bit about them, sort of their moods, what they look like when they're hungry or they're hunting, you can be much more efficient in your ability to get away.
你会把时间花在奔跑上，而不是吃草。这实际上会让你在以后被捕获的风险更高。所以这是逻辑的一个方面。另一个方面是，如果你对你的天然捕食者知之甚少，你就处于一种不妙的境地，对吧？对它们保持好奇对你有好处，因为如果你能对它们有所了解——比如它们的情绪、它们饥饿或狩猎时的样子——你在逃跑时的效率就会大大提高。
So we've talked about the many ways that humans are drawn to stories of violence and danger, things that ought to be aversive and unpleasant. You believe that our proclivity to seek out information about dangerous and disturbing things is similar to the interests that the monkey showed in the live snake. And you call this morbid curiosity. What do you mean by the term? Well, it's a commonly misunderstood term, I think. You know, if you hear the term morbid with another word, you often think of that thing as being bad.
我们已经讨论了人类被暴力和危险的故事所吸引的种种方式，这些本该是令人反感和不愉快的事情。你认为我们寻求有关危险和令人不安的事物的倾向，与猴子对活蛇表现出的兴趣相似。你称之为病态好奇（morbid curiosity）。你这个术语是什么意思？嗯，我认为这是一个常被误解的术语。你知道的，如果你听到“病态”（morbid）这个词与另一个词连用，你通常会认为那件事是不好的。
And in the case of morbid curiosity, I don't mean that the curiosity is bad. I mean that people are curious about things that are bad. So the curiosity itself is not pathological, it's not bad. But because the object of the curiosity is about a potential thing. threat. I've called it morbid curiosity. And so, you know, the definition that I've used for morbid curiosity is simply an interest in or curiosity about threats. And this could be visual information. It could be auditory information, you know, any kind of information about something that is dangerous or could be dangerous. You say that the concept of morbid curiosity in some
但在病态好奇的情况下，我并不是指好奇心不好。我的意思是，人们对不好的事情感到好奇。所以好奇心本身并不是病态的，也不是坏事。但由于好奇心的对象是一个潜在的威胁，我称之为病态好奇。所以，你知道的，我所使用的关于病态好奇的定义很简单：对威胁的兴趣或好奇。这可以是视觉信息。它可以是听觉信息，你知道的，任何关于某种危险或可能有危险的事物的各种信息。你提到病态好奇的概念在某种程度上
way speaks to the puzzle that we have been discussing. On the one hand, we denounce violence and anti-social behavior, but on the other hand, we are drawn to seeing it and hearing about it? Correct. Throughout time and across cultures, violence usually is seen as bad. It's usually punished. But the interesting thing is that even in cultures that are the most anti-violence in most circumstances, they often have certain rituals or certain events where violence is not only seen as okay, but it's maybe celebrated. And it was really intriguing to me that people could have these completely opposing views on how moral something is, depending on what kind of situation it occurs. What do you think watching a film like Contagion did to people as they
解答了我们一直在讨论的谜题。一方面，我们谴责暴力和反社会行为，但另一方面，我们又被观看和听到它所吸引？没错。纵观历史和各个文化，暴力通常被视为坏事。它通常会受到惩罚。但有趣的是，即使在大多数情况下最反感暴力的文化中，它们也常常有某些仪式或某些活动，在这些活动中暴力不仅被视为没问题，甚至可能受到赞美。这真的让我很着迷，人们对某种东西有多高的道德评价，竟然可以根据它发生的情境而产生这种完全相反的看法。科尔顿，你认为观看像《传染病》这样的电影，在人们艰难应对新冠疫情的不确定性时，起到了什么作用？
struggled with the uncertainty of the COVID pandemic, Colton? You know, if you're if you're introduced to something that's new, what do you want to do? Well, you want to learn about it, right? And if you're introduced to something that scientists in particular are just now kind of trying to figure out, you know, in February and March of 2020, a lot of mistakes were made. People were kind of seeing the scientific method in action. They were seeing how science works in action, which is, you know, you think something might be true, and you test it, and maybe it is, and maybe it isn't. And I think people aren't used to that. And so the next best thing that they had, the best cohesive story that people had was, in this case, contagion. It was a film about a pandemic and about the social response to that pandemic, about how the virus spread and what it did to you.
你知道的，如果你接触到某种新事物，你想做什么？嗯，你想了解它，对吧？如果你接触到的某种事物，恰好是科学家们特别是刚刚开始摸索的东西——你知道的，在2020年2月和3月，犯了很多错误。人们在见证科学方法发挥作用，他们看到了科学是如何运作的，也就是，你知道的，你认为某事可能是真的，然后你测试它，也许它是真的，也许不是。我认为人们不习惯那样。因此，他们拥有的次优选择、人们拥有的最佳连贯故事就是，在这个例子中，那就是《传染病》。这是一部关于大流行以及社会对该大流行的反应的电影，关于病毒如何传播以及它对你做了什么，
and it was a neatly packaged, well-told story in about 90 minutes that people could consume. So in some ways, Colton, this puts a different spin on students who go to see a violent movie after something bad has happened on that college campus. Correct, yeah. That study came out in the 1970s, and these scientists didn't call what they were observing morbid curiosity. But that's exactly what they were measuring. That's what they were finding was a morbidly curious behavior in these college students who presumably felt an urge to learn about interpersonal violence. And again, you know, an easy way for them to do that is to go see a movie.
它是一个被整洁打包、讲得很好、大约90分钟的故事，人们可以吸收它。所以从某种程度上说，科尔顿，这为那些在大学校园发生坏事后去看暴力电影的学生们提供了一个不同的视角。没错，是的。那项研究发表于20世纪70年代，这些科学家并没有将他们观察到的现象称为病态好奇。但那正是他们当时在测量的东西。他们发现的正是这些大学生身上表现出的病态好奇行为，这些学生大概感受到了了解人际暴力的冲动。再次强调，你知道的，他们做到这一点的简单方法就是去看电影。
I can think of all kinds of other examples from the news. You know, something bad happens. there's a serial killer on the loose, and suddenly we're all very fascinated with psychopathy. And it's not necessarily because we're interested in psychopaths, but we're saying something dangerous is out there. Let me learn about it. In some ways, it's a form of predator inspection. Exactly right. Yeah, I think a lot of the neural mechanisms are probably conserved across mammals for predator evasion, predator inspection, just general threat management when it comes to. predators. If a zebra had the ability to write a book or create a documentary or a fiction film, it would almost certainly create many of those about lions. And I think the same is true
我能想到新闻中的各种其他例子。你知道的，发生了坏事。有连环杀手在逃，突然之间我们都对精神病态非常着迷。这不一定是因为我们对精神病态者感兴趣，而是我们在说：外面有危险的东西。让我去了解一下。从某种程度上说，这是一种捕食者监视。完全正确。是的，我认为许多神经机制可能在哺乳动物中都是保守的，用于逃避捕食者、监视捕食者，以及处理有关捕食者的一般威胁管理。如果斑马有能力写书、制作纪录片或虚构电影，它几乎肯定会制作许多关于狮子的作品。我认为如果瞪羚也能做到这一点，
if gazelles, they would be creating media entertainment about cheetahs, right? And I think humans do the same thing. The only difference between other animals and their form of morbid curiosity and humans in their form of morbid curiosity is that humans can actually create stories where they're not exposed to the danger, right? So if a gazelle wants to learn something about a cheetah, it has to be there in person and there's a much higher risk associated with that. Humans, on the other hand, can consume a story that someone else has created either because they've had a personal experience with this danger or because they understand how this danger works and they can put it actually in a new context in which nobody has ever experienced this danger, but they might.
它们也会制作关于猎豹的媒体娱乐内容，对吧？我认为人类也是如此。其他动物的病态好奇形式与人类的病态好奇形式之间唯一的区别在于，人类实际上可以创造出他们不会暴露在危险之中的故事，对吧？因此，如果一只瞪羚想要了解一些关于猎豹的事情，它必须亲自到场，而这会带来高得多的风险。另一方面，人类可以消费别人创作的故事，这可能是因为他们对这种危险有个人经历，或者因为他们了解这种危险是如何运作的，并且他们可以将其置于一个前所未有、谁也没有经历过这种危险的新语境中，尽管他们未来可能会经历。
So humans have this incredible ability to forecast into possible futures and imagine what kinds of behaviors are adaptive, what kinds of behaviors are maladaptive, and what these things might look like, how we can prepare for them, how we might see them coming before they actually arrive. So it's much safer, in other words, to sit in a movie theater. with a bag of popcorn in your hand and hear a story about a terrifying killer shark that's on the loos than to actually be in the waters of the ocean and potentially have to encounter the shark.
因此，人类具有这种令人难以置信的能力，可以预测可能的未来，并想象什么样的行为是适应性的、什么样的行为是不适应性的，以及这些事情可能会是什么样子，我们如何为它们做准备，如何在它们实际到来之前看到它们的到来。换句话说，坐在电影院里，手里拿着一袋爆米花，听一个关于一条可怕的、在外面游荡的杀手鲨鱼的故事，要比真正身处海洋水中、可能不得不遭遇鲨鱼要安全得多。
Correct, yeah. And one of the questions I get a lot is, well, if that's true, why don't we just read science textbooks about sharks in that case? Or why don't we read science textbooks about pandemics instead of watching contagion? And I think the answer is that, you know, humans are storytelling creatures. We learn really well, despite the fact that we can experience a situation cognitively without actually being in the presence of it. You know, we come from a 500 million year line of organisms that have developed brains that can only understand experience in a first person perspective. And that's exactly what stories do is they give you a first person perspective of what it's like to be somewhere and experience a thing.
没错，是的。我经常遇到的一个问题是：好吧，如果这是真的，那为什么我们不直接去读关于鲨鱼的科学教科书呢？或者为什么我们不读关于大流行的科学教科书，而是去看《传染病》？我认为答案是，你知道的，人类是会讲故事的生物。我们学习得非常好，尽管我们可以在认知上体验一种情况而无需实际身处其中。你知道的，我们来自一个拥有5亿年历史的生物进化链，这些生物进化出的大脑只能从第一人称视角理解经验。而这正是故事所做的，它们为你提供了一个关于身临其境并体验某事的 pierwszej osoby（第一人称）视角。
And so stories kind of, you know, are crafted in a way that tap into these evolutionarily old parts of our mind that are just used to dealing with everyday experience. And so we consume them more easily. We remember things from them more easily. And, you know, in small-scale societies, most things are told as stories. They're not told as a list of facts. Your research has found that watching content like horror movies can help make people more psychologically resilient. How so, Colton? This was one of the more interesting things out of my career so far, I think, was finding that being a horror fan, you know, watching scary movies or reading scary books, seems to actually have an effect on how resilient you are to real dangers in the world.
所以故事某种程度上，你知道的，它们的制作方式能够触及我们心智中这些古老的进化部分，这些部分习惯于处理日常生活经验。因此我们更容易吸收它们。我们更容易从中记住事情。而且，你知道的，在小规模社会中，大多数事情都是作为故事来讲述的。它们不会被当作一连串的事实来讲述。你的研究发现，观看恐怖电影等内容可以帮助人们变得在心理上更具韧性。科尔顿，怎么会这样呢？我认为这是我迄今为止的职业生涯中最有趣的发现之一，那就是成为一名恐怖片粉丝——你知道的，看恐怖电影或读恐怖书——似乎确实对你应对现实世界危险的韧性产生了影响。
And so I first found this in the early months of the COVID-19 pandemic. You know, we recruited a couple hundred people using online platforms because, of course, we couldn't bring people into the lab. And what we found was that people who were horror fans, uniquely, were more resilient to the stresses of the pandemic. So even when we controlled for Big Five personality, we controlled for age, we controlled for income, we controlled for sex, we controlled for all these things we could think of that might influence resilience. And we still found that if you watched horror movies, you were more resilient during those early months of the pandemic. People who were horror fans were experiencing less psychological distress.
所以我最初在2019冠状病毒病（COVID-19）大流行的最初几个月里发现了这一点。你知道的，我们通过在线平台招募了几百人，因为我们当然不能把人们带进实验室。而我们发现的是，恐怖片粉丝在面对大流行的压力时，具有独特的更强韧性。因此，即使当我们控制了人格五因素模型（Big Five personality）、控制了年龄、控制了收入、控制了性别、控制了所有我们能想到的可能影响韧性的因素之后。我们仍然发现，如果你看恐怖电影，你在大流行初期会更有韧性。恐怖片粉丝经历的心理困扰更少。
So they were experiencing, to a lesser degree, anxiety, insomnia, you know, sleeplessness, depression. They were experiencing those physiological symptoms of stress, much less than people who were not horror fans. And when we looked at morbidly curious people, and we isolated that variable by itself, we found that people who scored high in morbid curiosity were experiencing much more positive resilience. So they were much more optimistic about their ability to kind of get through these difficult times. They were feeling, you know, despite how difficult the world was, they kind of maintained their optimism about humanity and about their ability to persevere. I'm wondering if it's also possible that as we watch the movie about the scary shark
因此，他们经历的焦虑、失眠、睡眠不足、抑郁的程度要轻得多。他们经历的压力生理症状，要远少于不是恐怖片粉丝的人。当我们观察病态好奇的人，并将该变量单独隔离出来时，我们发现病态好奇得分高的人体验到了更多的积极韧性。因此，他们对度过这些艰难时期的能力要乐观得多。他们感觉到，你知道的，尽管世界多么艰难，他们依然保持着对人类的乐观以及对他们坚持不懈能力的信心。我在想，这也是不是有可能，当我们看关于可怕鲨鱼的电影
or the movie about the serial killer, in some ways it takes our minds off of the things that are worrying us in our real lives. In other words, the fear of the artificial threat in some ways replaces the fear of the real threat and in some ways mitigates how frightened we are in real life. Yeah, that's exactly right. Right. You know, you would think that if you're feeling stressed, you might go watch a feel-good movie, watch a comedy or a rom-com or something that would make you feel good, right? But what's really interesting is people don't seem to do that as often as they seem to seek out scary things or things that are difficult to engage with when they're feeling bad. And this really intrigued me. And I kind of, you know, there was no research on this when I first started thinking about this conundrum, this paradox. And what I was finding were a lot of horror fans who would write about this experience. They would write about their personal experience overcoming their anxiety with horror.
或者关于连环杀手的电影时，它在某种程度上把我们的注意力从现实生活中让我们担忧的事情上转移开了。换句话说，对人工制造威胁的恐惧在某种程度上取代了对现实威胁的恐惧，并且在某种程度上减轻了我们在现实生活中感受到的恐惧？是的，完全正确。对。你知道的，你可能会认为，如果你感到压力，你可能会去看一部温馨的电影，看一部喜剧或浪漫喜剧或能让你感觉良好的东西，对吧？但真正有趣的是，当人们感觉不好的时候，他们似乎不像人们想象的那样经常去看那些东西，反而更倾向于寻找恐怖的事物或那些难以应付的事物。这真的让我很着迷。我当时——当我开始思考这个谜题、这个悖论时，没有任何关于这方面的研究。而我发现的是许多恐怖片粉丝会写下这种经历。他们会写下自己通过恐怖片克服焦虑的个人经历。
And they'll write about this on online message boards like Reddit, for example, or they would write op-eds and magazines. And many times, you know, they would accidentally discover this and they don't understand quite why it works. But they were noticing that when they would watch the scary movie, it seemed to kind of calm them down. And so I started, you know, I started thinking about this, like, how could this possibly work? What are the, what are the mechanisms here? You know, if this really does work in some people, what could be going on? So I think what's happening here is when you are feeling anxious about something, in particular if you're feeling kind of a generalized anxiety, you know, you're not really sure what you're anxious about, but you're getting the sweaty palms,
他们会在像红迪网（Reddit）这样的在线留言板上写下这些，或者他们会为杂志撰写专栏文章。很多时候，你知道的，他们是偶然发现了这一点，并且他们不太明白为什么它会管用。但他们注意到，当他们看恐怖电影时，它似乎能让他们平静下来。所以我开始，你知道的，我开始思考这个问题：这怎么可能行得通？这里的机制是什么？如果这在某些人身上真的管用，那会发生什么？所以我认为这里发生的情况是，当你对某事感到焦虑时，特别是如果你感到某种广义的焦虑——你知道的，你其实并不确定你在焦虑什么，但你的手心开始出汗，
the racing heart, you're feeling vigilant. That just kind of sits in this cycle, this, this vigilance cycle where your vigilance is looking for a potential threat and it can't find it so it turns up the vigilance even more to try to find it and it still can't find it. And those are the cycles of rumination that are pretty familiar to people with anxiety. And what's interesting is, you know, our minds are exceptionally attuned to threats. So threats pretty much overpower any other stimulus in our field of view and our mind. And that makes sense because if there's something threatening in your environment, you should kind of pay attention to that over other things. The problem, of course, is in humans, we don't often have threatening things in our
心跳加速，你感到警惕。这种情况就会陷入这种循环中，这个警惕循环：你的警惕性在寻找一个潜在的威胁，却找不到，于是它把警惕性调得更高来试图找到它，却依然找不到。这些就是焦虑症患者相当熟悉的反复思量循环。有趣的是，你知道的，我们的心智对威胁异常敏感。因此威胁几乎会压倒我们视野和心智中的任何其他刺激。这很合理，因为如果你的环境中有什么具威胁性的东西，你应该把注意力放在那上面，而不是其他事情上。问题当然在于，在人类中，我们的环境中通常没有具威胁性的东西，
environment, but we have them in our heads. And so I thought, well, maybe horror kind of is like fighting fire with fire because you're giving your mind something threatening to latch onto. You know, you're giving it a killer on the screen or a, you know, in the case of true crime, like a serial story about a serial killer or in horror or the story of this terrible monster. And what that does is it does a much better job of kind of dislodging this cycle of rumination. You can imagine it kind of like a highway off ramp, you know, for your mind so that you can get out of that. And then now you're sucked into the movie or a book works just as well for many people. You're sucked into this story, let's say, the scary story. And you're still
但它们在我们的脑子里。所以我想，嗯，也许恐怖片有点像是以毒攻毒，因为你给你的心智提供了一个具有威胁性的东西去依附。你知道的，你给它一个屏幕上的杀手，或者，在真实犯罪的情况下，一个关于连环杀手的系列故事，或者在恐怖片中，一个可怕怪物的传说。而这样做的好处是，它能更好地打破这种反刍思维的循环。你可以把它想象成你心智的高速公路匝道，你知道的，这样你就可以摆脱那种状态。然后现在你被吸进电影里了——或者一本书对许多人来说同样有效。你被吸进这个故事里，比方说，这个恐怖的故事中。你依然
feeling anxious. You haven't solved that problem yet. But the difference now is that you have control over the source of the anxiety. It's identifiable. you know what you're anxious about you have some control over it you can put the book down you can pause the movie you can sit with a friend and watch it you can do things that make you feel safer you can collect yourself right or you can kind of as the movie's playing through some of the less scary scenes you can kind of collect your yourself a bit and then after 90 minutes the movie ends the threat goes away and that triggers to your to your mind like hey the threat is we found the threat now it's gone now what's called the parasympathetic nervous
感到焦虑。你还没有解决那个问题。但现在的不同之处在于，你对焦虑的来源有了控制。它是可识别的，你知道你在为什么感到焦虑，你对它有一定的控制力，你可以把书放下，你可以暂停电影，你可以和朋友坐在一起看它，你可以做一些让你感到更安全的事情，你可以让自己镇定下来，对吧？或者你可以——随着电影播放一些不太恐怖的场景——稍微平静一下自己，然后90分钟后电影结束了，威胁消失了，这向你的心智触发了一个信号：嘿，威胁——我们找到了威胁，现在它消失了。现在所谓的副交感神经系统被激活了。
system. This is the part of your mind that controls the, you can think of it like as the rest and digest part of your nervous system. It helps you kind of relax. That part of your nervous system kicks in and it helps physiologically calm you down. You've been exploring the idea that people might sometimes you, scary entertainment as a way to connect with other people. What do you mean by this? You know, we talked about earlier how humans are or storytelling creatures. A lot of our time is spent talking with others, telling others about things, experiencing
这是你心智中控制——你可以把它想象成你神经系统的“休息和消化”部分。它能帮你放松下来。你神经系统的那个部分开始发挥作用，并在生理上帮助你平静下来。你一直在探索这样一种观点：人们有时可能会将恐怖娱乐作为一种与他人建立联系的方式。你这是什么意思？你知道的，我们之前讨论过人类是会讲故事的生物。我们的很多时间都花在与他人交谈、向他人讲述事情、体验
these fictional worlds or past experiences or future possibilities with others. And sometimes those are scary stories, scary events that might happen or scary events that did happen or scary fictions that could happen. uh and so again you know we kind of just took the next natural extension of this you have okay well maybe some people who are anxious seem drawn to horror and it helps them because it gets them out of a cycle of rumination and then the kind of next step of that is okay if they do this a lot they might actually be building some skills and learning something about themselves but then if you you know if you go to a haunted attraction in october or you go to a new screening of a new horror
与他人分享这些虚构的世界、过去的经历或未来的可能性。有时这些是可怕的故事、可能发生的恐怖事件、曾经发生的恐怖事件，或是可能发生的恐怖虚构情境。所以，我们再次顺理成章地将这一思路延伸下去：有些焦虑的人似乎会被恐怖片吸引，这能帮助他们摆脱反刍思维的循环。接下来的合乎逻辑的一步就是，如果他们经常这样做，实际上可能是在培养一些技能，并对自我有所了解。但如果你在十月去鬼屋，或者去看一场新的
movie at a theater what you notice is that most people are there with someone else and this is especially true at haunted attractions uh and what's especially interesting at haunted attractions there's two things here one of them is that you know they open usually in late september and they're open through Halloween that's kind of their prime season but if they're open another time of year it's almost always during valentine's day it's during it's during a holiday where we spend time with those we love the most um and it's kind of it was kind of of intriguing to me that that's when they were open, right? And if you go to a haunted house in October, what you notice is that a lot of people are there with their significant other. If you go to a
电影院上映的新恐怖片，你会发现大多数人都是和别人一起去的，鬼屋尤其如此。在鬼屋里，特别有趣的是有两点：第一，它们通常在九月底开业，一直营业到万圣节，这是它们的黄金档期；但如果它们在一年中的其他时间营业，几乎总是在情人节，也就是我们和最爱的人共度时光的节日。对我来说，它们在那时候营业挺耐人寻味的，对吧？如果你在十月去鬼屋，你会发现很多人都是和另一半一起去的。如果你去
horror movie, what you notice is a lot of people are there with their significant other, their spouse or their boyfriend or fiancee or girlfriend. And so we think kind of this next natural extension of our thinking here was that, well, maybe you're not only learning something about yourself, but maybe you're also learning something about the people around you. Because you're seeing how they respond in these sort of playful simulations of fear. So for example, you know, if I go through a haunted attraction with a friend and my friend acts protective towards me and kind of we stick together, right? That's kind of a good clue that maybe they're a good cooperative partner. But if I go to this simulation and I see them kind of lose their cool a little bit and they
恐怖电影，你会发现很多人都是和他们的另一半、配偶、男朋友、未婚夫或女朋友一起去的。因此，我们认为这自然延伸出的下一个想法是：好吧，你不仅在了解自己，可能还在了解周围的人。因为你看到他们在这种好玩的恐惧模拟中如何反应。举个例子，如果我和朋友一起去鬼屋，我的朋友表现得对我很保护，而且我们俩形影不离，对吧？这算是一个不错的线索，表明他们可能是一个好的、有合作精神的伙伴。但如果我去了这个模拟体验，看到他们有点情绪失控，然后
leave me behind or, you know, they don't, they don't cooperate with me in these, in this simulation of a fearful experience. It might be an indication that they're not going to cooperate with me in a real situation that's, that's threatening. And so we could be learning not only about ourselves, but about, you know, potential partners or friends in these situations. I mean, I'm thinking even of little kids during Halloween. I mean, who goes trick or treating just by themselves? The whole fun is to go with other little kids and to scream and terror together. In some ways, it is a very social activity.
把我抛在身后，或者，你知道的，他们不配合我，不在这种恐惧体验的模拟中与我合作。这可能预示着在现实中面临威胁的情况时，他们也不会与我合作。因此，在这些情境中，我们不仅能了解自己，还能了解潜在的伴侣或朋友。我的意思是，甚至连万圣节的小朋友也是如此。谁会自己一个人去不给糖就捣蛋呢？整个活动的乐趣就在于和其他小朋友一起去，一起尖叫、一起体验恐惧。从某种程度上说，这是一个非常社交化的活动。
And, of course, I think the idea that horror movies might make for good date night movies or date movies, I think that's well established. Yeah, some of the earliest work on horror movies was research on couples and what couples do when they go to a scary movie and this was kind of dubbed the the snuggle theory of horror and this early idea was that that the reason people enjoyed horror movies was because they could kind of live out these cultural expectations of how they were supposed to react so for example if a man and a woman go on a date to a horror movie there's an expectation that the man will act kind of brave and it'll give him a good excuse to kind of bring his female counterpart closer to him and the woman will have this expectation of the man that he will act brave as well but also that
当然，我认为恐怖电影适合作为约会电影的这种观点已经深入人心了。是的，早期关于恐怖电影的一些研究是针对情侣的，研究情侣去看恐怖片时会做什么。这被称为恐怖片的“依偎理论”。早期的观点认为，人们喜欢恐怖电影的原因是他们可以借此实现人们在面对恐怖时的文化预期。例如，如果男女约会去看恐怖电影，会有一种期望：男生要表现得勇敢，这能给他一个好借口去亲近女伴；而女生对男生的期望则是男生也要表现得勇敢，
she might be a little fearful and give him the opportunity to act brave right give him see if he will act brave when she's afraid it's commonly feared that people who are drawn to dark and disturbing content must themselves harbor unsavory qualities. When we come back, are horror aficionados, people to be feared, or some of the nicest people around? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Are you a fan of dark and sinister tales?
而且她可能会有点害怕，从而给他一个表现勇敢的机会，对吧——看看她在害怕时他是否会表现勇敢。人们普遍担心，那些被黑暗和不安内容吸引的人自身必然怀有令人不快的特质。稍后回来，恐怖片爱好者究竟是让人恐惧的人，还是周围最和善的人？欢迎收听《隐藏的心智》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。你是黑暗阴暗故事的粉丝吗？
Do you find yourself gravitating to stories of crime and vengeance? Do you sometimes feel guilty about the books you read and the TV you consume? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience about your interests in the eerie or the macabre, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org with the subject line, scary.
你是否发现自己不由自主地被犯罪和复仇的故事所吸引？你是否有时会对你读的书和看的电视感到内疚？如果你愿意与《隐藏的心智》听众分享一个关于你对诡异或恐怖事物兴趣的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将其发电子邮件至 Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org，主题行写上“scary”（恐怖）。
Again, that's ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Across the animal kingdom, creatures large and small seem to be fascinated by their predators. Humans are no exception. We devour books and movies about pathogens and pandemics, terrorists and traders, serial killers, and psychopaths. Colton's Krivner is a researcher at Arizona State University and Orhus University in Denmark.
再重复一遍，邮箱是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。在动物王国里，无论大小生物似乎都对它们的捕食者着迷。人类也不例外。我们如饥似渴地阅读和观看关于病原体和大流行病、恐怖分子和叛徒、连环杀手和精神病患者的书籍和电影。科尔顿·克里夫纳是亚利桑那州立大学和丹麦奥胡斯大学的研究员。
He is the author of Morbidly Curious. A scientist explains why we can't look away. In the early 1980s, Colton, a new generation of super-gory horror films hit the theaters. Audiences loved them, but many observers were appalled. Here's film critic Roger Ebert, sharing his view about one such film. Our next movie is Friday the 13th,
他是《病态好奇：科学家解释我们为什么无法移开视线》一书的作者。在20世纪80年代初，科尔顿，新一代充斥着血腥场面的恐怖电影登陆各大影院。观众们很喜欢，但许多观察家却感到震惊。以下是影评人罗杰·伊伯特对其中一部此类电影的看法。我们下一部电影是《十三号星期五》
the final chapter, an immoral and reprehensible piece of trash that sold more tickets on his opening weekend than any other movie so far in the night. 1984. And that is a very, very depressing commentary. It really makes me sad to think of all those moviegoers, most of them teenage kids sitting there watching this sad, cynical, depressing movie. Colton, what do you hear in that expression of outrage about the content of horror movies and the people who go to see them? So Roger Ebert hosted this show with Gene Siskel, and they were two of the most well-respected, popular movie critics of their time. So Roger
终章，这是一部不道德且令人发指的垃圾，它在首映周末卖出的票数比1984年至今的任何其他电影都要多。这是一个非常、非常令人沮丧的评论。想到所有那些电影观众，其中大部分是十几岁的孩子，坐在那里看着这部悲伤、玩世不恭、令人沮丧的电影，真的让我感到难过。科尔顿，你从这种对恐怖电影内容及其观众的愤怒表达中听出了什么？罗杰·伊伯特曾与吉恩·西斯克尔共同主持这个节目，他们是那个时代最受尊敬、最受欢迎的两位影评人。所以罗杰
Ebert, they're obviously saying that it was a real shame that people were watching this morally depraved movie. And Gene Siskel chimes in a bit later by saying that people who enjoy it are are obviously depraved and they hate women. And what struck me about this clip when I watched it for the first time was that the film critics weren't criticizing the film. I mean, they were, but they were even more so, they were criticizing people who watched the film, which is unusual, I think for a film critic to do. And, you know, you might think, well, maybe that only happened in the 1980s because that's when slasher's kind of cropped up, right?
伊伯特，他们显然是在说，人们观看这部道德沦丧的电影真是一个巨大的耻辱。而吉恩·西斯克尔稍后插话称，喜欢它的人显然已经道德沦丧，并且仇恨女性。当我第一次看到这段剪辑时，让我震惊的是，影评人们并不是在批评这部电影。我的意思是，他们确实在批评，但更重要的是，他们在批评观看电影的人，这对于影评人来说是不寻常的。你知道，你可能会想，好吧，这可能只发生在20世纪80年代，因为那是杀人狂电影开始兴起的时候，对吧？
Halloween success drove filmmakers to make, you know, hundreds of these slasher movies, the most successful of which right afterwards was Friday of the 13th. And these were, you know, goryer. They were more violent, sure. And Roger Ebert and Gene Siskel and many other critics hated these films, thought they were just, as you said, they're a poor indication of the health of society, if you will, especially of young people, of teenagers. So, yeah, I mean, what I hear there is not a film critic criticizing a film, but a film
万圣节的成功促使电影制作人拍摄了数百部此类杀人狂电影，其中紧随其后最成功的就是《十三号星期五》。这些电影当然更加血腥，更加暴力。罗杰·伊伯特、吉恩·西斯克尔以及许多其他影评人都讨厌这些电影，认为它们正如你所说，可以说是社会健康状况糟糕的表现，特别是对年轻人、对十几岁青少年的影响。所以，是的，我的意思是，我在那里听到的不是影评人在批评一部电影，而是一位影评人
critic criticizing the sort of moral standing of the film's fans. There was a movie critic. from the New York Post who wrote a blistering review about the movie series Saw, where he says that people who watch these movies are, quote, depraved lunatics who should
在批评这部电影粉丝的某种道德立场。曾有一位来自《纽约邮报》的影评人对电影《电锯惊魂》系列写了一篇尖锐的评论，他在其中说，观看这些电影的人是“堕落的疯子，不应该被允许靠近动物或大多数其他生物”。
not be allowed near animals or most other living things. So it's not just that there's something wrong with these people for watching these movies, but that we should be afraid of these people who go and watch these movies. Well, it's worth seeing two things. I mean, one, are they right? Are people who are horror fans
所以，这不仅是因为这些人看这些电影有什么不对，而是我们应该害怕那些去看这些电影的人。嗯，有两件事值得一看。我的意思是，首先，他们说得对吗？恐怖片粉丝
low in empathy? Are they not compassionate, not kind, you know, terrible people. As much as I didn't want that to be true, I was open to the possibility, right? Because I'm sympathetic to the intuition that if you can watch really violent things and be okay with it and even enjoy it, that maybe it says something about your psyche or your, whether or not you approve of violence. I'm sympathetic to that intuition. But as far as I knew, there were really, you know, there was no empirical work that had really shown this. And so the very first thing I did was I actually ran a study where I created these fake user profiles, you know, like you might see on an early version of a social media website where it's just a person's name, their age, whether they were a man or woman, and their favorite movie genre. And I created hundreds of these profiles that were just randomized, you know.
同理心低下吗？他们是否缺乏同情心、不善良，或者是非常糟糕的人？尽管我不希望这是真的，但我对这种可能性持开放态度，对吧？因为我同情这种直觉：如果你能观看非常暴力的内容却安然无恙甚至乐在其中，这或许能说明一些关于你心理的问题，或者说明你是否认可暴力。我同情这种直觉。但据我所知，确实（你知道的），没有任何实证研究真正证明了这一点。所以我做的第一件事其实是进行了一项研究，我创建了这些虚假的个人资料，你知道，就像你在早期版本的社交网站上可能会看到的那样，上面只有个人的名字、年龄、是男是女，以及他们最喜欢的电影类型。我创建了数百个这种只是随机生成的个人资料。
And I presented them to participants, and I asked the participants to kind of guess, like what they think this person is. like. You know, with minimal information, what can you discern about this individual? And I'd ask them to guess this individual's personality, you know, their big five traits, but also, you know, how empathetic do you think they are? How compassionate do you think they are? How kind. And what I found was that people were much more likely to say that, you know, if one of the profiles said that the favorite movie genre of that individual was horror, they were much more likely to say that that individual is likely to be unkind, not compassionate, and lacking in empathy. That really said to me like, okay, it's not just movie critics.
我把它们展示给参与者，并要求参与者猜测这些人是什么样的。你知道，通过极少的信息，你能看出这个个体的什么特点？我让他们猜测这个人的个性，你知道的，他们的“大五人格”特质，还有，你知道的，你认为他们有多强的同理心？你认为他们有多富有同情心？有多善良。而我发现的是，如果某个个人资料显示该个体最喜欢的电影类型是恐怖片，人们明显更有可能说这个个体可能是不善良的、缺乏同情心的，并且缺乏同理心。这真的告诉我，好吧，不仅仅是影评人。
You know, it's regular people kind of have this intuition. So then I was like, okay, I really have to study this and see if it's true. So I ran a series of studies. But what I found was that all of my horror fans looked just like regular people. Look like I had a group of non-horror fans kind of as my control. and they looked just like them. There was no relationship between how much of a horror fan you were
你知道，普通人也有这种直觉。所以我当时想，好吧，我真的必须研究一下，看看这是不是真的。于是我进行了一系列研究。但我发现的是，我所有的恐怖片粉丝看起来都和普通人一模一样。就好像我有一群不看恐怖片的人作为对照组，而恐怖片粉丝看起来和他们一模一样。你对恐怖片的喜爱程度
and how empathetic you were. Except that now there was a couple of instances where I did find something significant, but interestingly, it was in the opposite direction as many people would expect. So some horror fans, and in particular those who like the paranormal horror movies, scored a bit higher in cognitive empathy.
与你的同理心之间没有任何关系。除了现在有几次我确实发现了一些显著的结果，但有趣的是，结果的方向与许多人的预期相反。一些恐怖片粉丝，特别是那些喜欢超自然恐怖片的人，在认知同理心上的得分略高一些。
So they were a bit better at taking the perspective of other people. what you're doing when you're engaging in a fictional story about someone's experience is you are imagining yourself in their shoes. I mean, you are literally engaging cognitive empathy, right? And when you see shots of their face on the film where it kind of zooms in on the victim, in this case of a horror film, the victim's face, you know, their screams of agony and their fear on their face, I mean, you're then, ideally, you're feeling that, right? You're feeling afraid and you're putting yourself in their situation. And if you're not doing that, you're probably not enjoying the
所以他们更擅长站在别人的角度思考问题。当你参与一个关于某人经历的虚构故事时，你在做什么？你在想象自己身处他们的鞋子里。我的意思是，你实际上是在调动认知同理心，对吧？当你在电影中看到特写他们的脸——在这个恐怖片的例子中，是受害者的脸——他们的痛苦尖叫和脸上的恐惧，我的意思是，然后，理想情况下，你正在感受那种恐惧，对吧？你在感受恐惧，并将自己置于他们的处境中。如果你没有这样做，你可能就不会享受
horror movie, right? When I buy a ticket to a horror film, I expect to feel afraid. I expect to be scared. And if I don't empathize with the protagonist, then I'm probably not going to feel afraid, right? We're not afraid of monsters because they kill people or they kill people on screen. We're afraid of monsters because they kill people who are like us, right? People we're imagining ourselves to be. That's what generates the fear. And so if you're not empathizing with the protagonist, in a horror film, you're probably not enjoying the horror film that much. Now, of course, could someone who is really violent, could they be empathizing with the killer? Sure, I suppose so.
恐怖电影，对吧？当我买票去看恐怖电影时，我期望感到害怕。我期望被吓到。如果我不能对主角产生同理心，那我大概就不会感到害怕，对吧？我们害怕怪物，不是因为它们杀人，也不是因为它们在银幕上杀人。我们害怕怪物，是因为它们杀害了像我们这样的人，对吧？是我们想象中自己成为的那种人。这才是恐惧产生的根源。因此，如果你在恐怖片中没有对主角产生同理心，你大概就不会那么享受这部恐怖电影。当然，有没有可能一个真正暴力的人是在对杀手产生同理心呢？当然，我想是的。
I mean, that's true of action movies as well. It's true of rom-coms where there's an evil partner, you know, a really bad toxic partner. You could be empathizing with them. I think that's not something that's unique with horror. I think in many cases, in many genres of film, people are empathizing with the protagonist. That's how stories are crafted to be understood. But I'm thinking back to movies like Jaws. You know, the movie is called Jaws.
我的意思是，动作片也是如此。浪漫喜剧中如果有一个邪恶的伴侣——一个非常糟糕、有毒的伴侣——也是如此。你可能会对他们产生同理心。我认为这不是恐怖片独有的现象。我认为在许多情况下，在许多电影类型中，人们都在对主角产生同理心。这就是故事被创作出来以便被理解的方式。但我想起了像《大白鲨》这样的电影。你知道，这部电影叫《大白鲨》。
It's about, it's about a shark, but really it's not about the shark at all. It's actually about how people are terrified about the shark, how they're frightened about the shark, how they're trying to defend themselves against the shark. It's really about the people, not the monster. I think that's exactly right. And that's a good example of where it would be kind of silly to say that people are empathizing with the antagonists. Like, are they imagining themselves as a shark? That's a strange argument to make, right? I think it's clear in a film like Jaws that people, like you said, are empathizing with
它讲的是、讲的是一条鲨鱼，但实际上它根本不是关于鲨鱼的。它其实是关于人们如何对鲨鱼感到恐惧，他们如何害怕鲨鱼，他们如何试图抵御鲨鱼。它真正讲的是人，而不是怪物。我认为这完全正确。这是一个很好的例子，如果在这种情况下说人们在对反派产生同理心，那就有点荒谬了。比如说，他们会把自己想象成一条鲨鱼吗？这是一个奇怪的论点，对吧？我认为在《大白鲨》这样的电影中很明显，正如你所说，人们是在与
and taking sort of the cognitive perspective of the protagonists and the danger they're in. There's another line of evidence that people who enjoy horror are, in fact, people who are empathetic. And that comes from the genre of the haunted house that involves a character known as a pleader. Can you describe one of these houses and who these characters are, Colton? Yeah, I was talking to Ben Armstrong, who owns Netherworld Haunted House in Georgia. It's one of the most well-known haunted attractions around Halloween. And I was telling him about this empathy study that I had just conducted because I was, you know, like, I was surprised by it. And I was asking him what he thought about it.
主角共情，并采取主角的认知视角去看待他们所处的危险。还有另一系列证据表明，喜欢恐怖片的人实际上是富有同理心的人。这来自于一种被称为“恳求者（pleader）”角色的鬼屋流派。你能描述一下其中一个鬼屋以及这些角色是谁吗，科尔顿？是的，我当时正在和本·阿姆斯多姆交谈，他是佐治亚州幽冥鬼屋（Netherworld Haunted House）的老板。这是万圣节期间最著名的鬼屋景点之一。我当时正跟他说我刚做完的这个同理心研究，因为我，你知道的，我自己也对结果感到惊讶。我问他作为
it as someone who is in the horror industry and he said you know it kind of makes sense he said in our industry we have what are called pleaders and these are usually like younger kids young women who are in the haunt who are actors they're actors in the in the experience um but in the story as you go through the haunt in the story they are seen as victim so they're like a uh a visitor who's been captured and is being held captive and as you go through the haunt house you kind of have the option to stop and try to help them escape or you can continue on right and maybe you think it's a trap or maybe you're too afraid to go try to help this person uh and you would think that most people who visit the haunted house would ignore the pleader because they know that
恐怖行业的一员，对此有什么看法。他说，这其实挺合理的。他说，在我们的行业里，有所谓的“恳求者”，这些通常是年纪较小的孩子、年轻女性，她们在鬼屋里担任演员。她们是体验项目中的演员，但在故事中，当你穿过鬼屋时，在剧情里她们被视为受害者。所以她们就像是一个被抓获并被关押的游客。当你穿过鬼屋时，你可以选择停下来试图帮助她们逃生，或者你可以继续往前走，对吧？也许你觉得这是一个陷阱，或者你太害怕而不敢去尝试帮助这个人。你可能会认为，大多数参观鬼屋的人都会忽略这个恳求者，因为他们知道
they're an actor it's no secret that this individual is probably an actor uh and there's no requirement to actually help this person right you can continue on as you please but he said you know what you find is that the pleaders are one of the more successful parts of the haunt. I mean, they almost always draw in with their cries of help. They almost always draw in these people who are at the haunted house to come help them. And a lot of that is, you know, they're activating the empathy response. They're activating, they look like vulnerable protagonists in this story or vulnerable, in this case, vulnerable side characters.
对方是个演员，这个人很可能是个演员，这并不是什么秘密，而且也没有人要求你必须去帮助这个人，对吧？你可以随心所欲地继续前行。但他却说，你知道吗，你会发现“恳求者”其实是鬼屋中最成功的环节之一。我的意思是，她们几乎总是能用她们的求救声，几乎总是能吸引那些在鬼屋里的人来帮助她们。这很大程度上是因为她们激活了同理心反应。她们激活了……在这个故事中，她们看起来像是脆弱的主角，或者脆弱的、在这种情况下脆弱的配角。
And they're, you know, activating the empathy response and the hauntgoers really well. Another real-life demonstration of this research finding that empathetic people might be the ones who are drawn to horror are so-called horror-themed restaurants. Tell me what a horror-themed restaurant is and why some of them seem to attract a clientele that is especially tender-hearted? Yeah, there's been kind of a recent crop of horror-themed restaurants. Is there restaurants that have themes that you would find in a horror movie or are themed like particular horror movies?
而且她们很好地激发了鬼屋游客的同理心反应。另一个现实生活中的例子，证明了这项研究的发现：富有同理心的人可能正是那些被恐怖片吸引的人，这就是所谓的恐怖主题餐厅。能告诉我什么是恐怖主题餐厅，以及为什么其中一些餐厅似乎吸引了特别心软的顾客群体吗？是的，最近涌现出了一批恐怖主题餐厅。这些餐厅的主题是你在恐怖电影中能找到的元素，或者是以特定的恐怖电影为主题的。
And you see this with bars and restaurants and sort of all kinds of almost experience-based establishments. And what's really interesting is that a lot of these horror-themed restaurants or coffee shops, they'll have a really high portion of vegan or vegetarian options. And you might think that someone who's a horror fan, you know, doesn't, again, as a, as the New York Post critics said, shouldn't be allowed around animals. But what's a little ironic is that many of these horror-themed restaurants are either vegetarian or vegan restaurants, or they have a huge aspect of their menu that caters to vegetarians and vegans. Presumably, horror fan vegans.
你在酒吧、餐厅以及各种几乎以体验为基础的场所都能看到这种现象。真正有趣的是，许多这类恐怖主题餐厅或咖啡馆，都会提供很高比例的素食或纯素选项。你可能会认为恐怖片粉丝，你知道的，正如《纽约邮报》影评人所说的那样，不应该被允许靠近动物。但有点讽刺的是，许多这类恐怖主题餐厅要么是素食或纯素餐厅，要么它们的菜单中有很大一部分是专门为素食主义者和纯素食主义者准备的。想必这些是素食主义的恐怖片粉丝。
I mean, in some ways, that runs against the idea that these people who watch these movies are sort of bloodthirsty people, almost by definition. Yeah. And, you know, I'm myself. I'm not a vegetarian or vegan. And I don't, you know, think that it necessarily says anything about the individual if they are or are not. But it certainly would be strange to have an individual who you think shouldn't be allowed around animals. And yet they are a vegetarian or a vegan, perhaps for moral reasons, right, for their own moral reasons. feels a natural inclination to feed their morbid curiosity. Maybe you're someone who scurries away when your spouse puts on a gory movie or cringes when your child plays a violent video game. And yet, maybe you're also curious about the psychological benefits of engaging with the dark side of life.
我的意思是，从某种程度上说，这与那些观看这些电影的人几乎生来就是嗜血之徒的观点背道而驰。是的。而且，你知道，我本人并不是素食主义者或纯素食主义者。我也不认为一个人是否是素食主义者必然能说明关于他个人的什么问题。但是，如果一个人你认为他不应该被允许靠近动物，而他却偏偏是一个素食主义者或纯素食主义者，可能是出于道德原因——为了他们自己的道德原因——那确实会显得很奇怪。感觉有一种自然的倾向去滋养他们病态的好奇心。也许当你的配偶播放血腥电影时，你是那个溜之大吉的人；或者当你的孩子玩暴力电子游戏时，你是那个感到畏缩的人。然而，也许你同时也对接触黑暗面所带来的心理益处感到好奇。
If so, our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus may be for you. It's called How to Enjoy the Chills. You can try Hidden Brain Plus with a free seven seven-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, those sites are support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. Colton Scrivener is a researcher at Arizona State University and Orhus University in Denmark. He's the author of Morbidly Curious. A scientist explains why we can't look away. Colton, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very
如果是这样，《隐藏的心智Plus》上的伴侣期节目可能非常适合你。它叫做《如何享受寒意》。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 免费试用七天的《隐藏的心智 Plus》。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com slash hiddenbrain。再次重复，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com slash hiddenbrain。科尔顿·克里夫纳是亚利桑那州立大学和丹麦奥胡斯大学的研究员。他是《病态好奇：科学家解释我们为什么无法移开视线》一书的作者。科尔顿，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的心智》。非常
much for having me on. Are you a fan of thrillers and murder mysteries? Do you love true crime podcasts? Does the idea of going to a haunted house or an escape room seem like great fun? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about morbid curiosity, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org with the subject line, scary. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
感谢邀请我来参加。你是惊悚片和谋杀悬疑片的粉丝吗？你喜欢真实犯罪播客吗？去鬼屋或密室逃脱的想法对你来说听起来很有趣吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的心智》听众分享一个个人故事，或者有关于病态好奇的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将其发送至 Feedback at hiddenbrain.org，主题行写上“scary”（恐怖）。再次重复，邮箱是 Feedback at hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的心智》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. This December, Hidden Brain is proud to join Pods Fight Poverty. We're teaming up with other podcasts to raise funds to live three villages in Rwanda out of extreme poverty. Your donation goes directly, no strings, no middlemen, to the families who know best what they need. visit givdirectly.org slash hidden brain to make a difference for someone who needs it most.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·克雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的心智》的执行编辑。今年12月，《隐藏的心智》很荣幸加入“播客抗击贫困”（Pods Fight Poverty）行动。我们正与其他播客合作筹集资金，帮助卢旺达的三个村庄摆脱极端贫困。你的捐款将直接发给最清楚自己需要什么的家庭，没有附加条件，没有中间商。请访问 givdirectly.org slash hiddenbrain，为最需要帮助的人带来改变。
That's give directly.org slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 givdirectly.org slash hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。